he inherited a very tough situation he
inherited a new EU treaty that mrs. may
had negotiated the plot was running down
he did his best to improve it to try and
get it ratified it didn't happen I'm
pleased at him now it didn't actually
represent for exit at all now there's a
general election was a great chance to
press the reset button drop the treaty
and then we can go for a genuine brexit
something based on trade not policy he
must know he will never drop withdrawal
the rumors that is not going to happen
so you are offering something which he
cannot accept is there any compromise on
your part we drop party labels of course
I'm very discreet this clear I've been
calling for a clean break brexit but I'm
quite prepared if he's gonna go for a
journeyman free-trade agreement but he
that's what he's going to do he said he
was but he's gonna do I'm sorry I mean
the terms that if you read the treaty
that he wants to ratify first and the
terms of approval declaration
it means full regulatory alignment for
the United Kingdom genuine free trade
deals don't have that I'm talking about
trade not politics and he goes for that
not only not in would we support him
he'd win a massive majority at the point
doesn't say there'll be regulatory
alignment difficult operations I've read
the political declaration it says
regulator alignment in Social Policy
employment policy environmental law and
thought Labour MP things labor and bees
are saying exactly opposite it's got
harder wait were they Harris junk were
they genuinely haven't read it but just
on the politics of it you must know that
he cannot suddenly turn around to his
parliamentary party to his part of the
European Union said well mr. baracs
wants me to drop it so I'm afraid I'm
gonna have to drop it all that work well
I tell you what it's a general election
they they give every party a chance to
start with a clean sheet that's what
general elections are for for goodness
sake so there is a chance to do it not
me do you think that they he think he
was that of course there's a chance to
do it and also let me say this the
longer the public have to look at that
withdrawal agreement the less happy
leave voters are going to be and and I
think if we get to December the 12th and
if he is trying to defend the withdrawal
agreement as brexit he's going to have a
very real problem a lot of people will
say you are making an offer that you
know he cannot accept any while playing
a very brexit live
you know everyone say I'm making an
offer we try to compromise I'm making
him an offer I desperately want him to
accept I want I think he can why not why
not because he just spent the last few
months negotiating something with the
European Union because his entire party
is that because he had a deadline
because he had a deadline to work
towards he was doing his best to deliver
it now it hasn't happened it's a chance
to think again and I'm urging him please
think again otherwise if it does go
through if he wins this election and
this goes through it is not brexit